hi this is pressure Locker see if you
can pass this personal finance quiz
imagine you're buying a calculator for a
hundred and twenty five dollars you will
learn that you can say five dollars by
making a ten-minute trip to a nearby
store do you make the trip now consider
a different situation
imagine you're buying a calculator
that's priced at twenty-five dollars you
again learn you can save five dollars by
going to a store that's ten minutes away
do you make the trip a famous study ask
people these questions in the first
scenario most people would not make the
trip to save five dollars they would
think that twenty they're spending one
hundred and twenty five dollars and five
dollar savings is not a lot of money in
the second situation however almost
everyone would make the trip it seems
like a lot if you're going to save five
dollars on a twenty five dollar
calculator however these two answers
make no sense they're inconsistent it's
the same five dollars in both situations
your decision should be based on whether
it's worth making a 10-minute trip to
save five dollars if you would make the
trip in one situation you should make
the trip in the second situation or if
you would make the trip you should not
make it in both situations the tendency
that we don't make the correct decision
is studied in behavioral economics and
the tendency is known as a decision trap
a cognitive bias or an irrational
decision these are not things that
should be surprising to us in fact we
experience these kinds of illusions all
the time consider the two diagrams of
circles on the left and the right I want
you to judge the size of the two orange
circles which have the five dollars does
either circle appear differently sized
to you most people would say the circle
on the left appears to be smaller
watch what happens however when I remove
the surrounding circles you'll see that
these details actually affect our
perception of size
the larger circles make the inside
circle appear smaller and the smaller
circle make the inside circle appear
larger when I remove the outside circles
and I draw grid lines you can see that
the two orange circles are exactly the
same size it's the same $5 when I put
the surrounding circles back and I
remove the grid lines the illusion once
again appears we are prone to make these
irrational decisions just as we are
prone to fall for optical illusions in
my new book the irrationality illusion
how to make smart decisions and overcome
bias I'll explain to you the many ways
that we make irrational decisions and
how you can identify the extraneous
details so that you can make a rational
decision by overcoming the bias that we
have check out the book there's a link
in the video description thanks for
watching this video please subscribe to
my channel I make videos on math and
game theory you can catch me on my blog
mind your decisions which you can follow
on Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
follow me on social media app press tell
Walker and you can check out links to
all my books in the video description